spee fore
fore
[Music]
for
okay yes it's audible now oh
okay so I can leave it here
right so there you go
yeah
all
right like it works all
right
all right so thank you everybody for for
a bit uh of patience uh so now we can
start with the event itself uh welcome
to the 27th P data uh three mastera
event uh we're very happy to to have you
here
today uh to to say just a few words
about the pataa
itself uh this event is a local branch
of uh multiple uh events happening all
around the world uh so everywhere uh
where you go you can uh imagine uh that
organizers are uh organizing uh the T
more independently the ts are different
uh but uh all is focus uh around
artificial intelligence uh data
processing in
general uh and uh the our our our not
partner but uh parent per se is n Focus
Foundation uh which is the uh Foundation
that supports multiple open source
projects like naai or ccii uh you might
be familiar with
uh uh the event wouldn't happen without
uh a lot of uh companies who help us and
people from these companies that stay
behind uh each contribution so first
thanks to park for hosting us here uh to
poman special uh economic uh space for
also uh combining the whole uh
possibility to uh host us here for kod
me Foundation as well and
interon uh we encourage you to check out
the Cod me foundation events opening
K venka who's today's piz sponsor uh
they're uh looking for python developers
uh if you want to know more details then
you can uh talk to me as well uh
gradient is a local academic Club so
they're uh more focused into very
in-depth workshops uh which they will be
starting uh soon in Octo in November
uh so there will be uh workshops that
are regular on gr University of
Technology and last but not least our
monthly local uh python Meetup piga uh
they will having they will have their uh
event also next Monday I believe 30th of
uh
October uh we have discod group uh was
uh was created a month ago go so you're
still welcome to to uh to to get into
the group itself uh where we discuss
different topics we haven't discussed
too much but I hope you'll have uh good
ideas for uh contributing to by data or
any any kind of uh uh initiatives you
would like to uh
extend uh leave us a message just as an
ending note for introduction to P data
itself there are different channels you
can uh find us uh through and uh let us
know about uh any kind of things you
like to let us know about not to say
that if you have an idea for
presentation to uh to give a talk then
just uh leave us a
message uh today we will'll be having
two uh presentations the first one uh
with vo chanowski from voic laab about
language models the second one with uh
ukash and good from Snowflake uh after a
little break so uh a quick
introduction uh vo works as anlp
researcher at voic lab and is pursuing
PhD uh at GL University of Technology
and let's welcome WF with round of
[Music]
applause
okay
work just one
again
right so okay um hello I'm
vosi and today my presentation is about
language models this is very fancy topic
I think so let's
start so this is I am I'm PhD student at
University of Technology I'm working at
graph
modeling real human
conversation and of course in at voice
lab I'm NLP engineer I working in fun
very fun and amazing NLP team and we
together working about TR this is
our first polish large language models
created by us completely not from
scratch that's we find
tuning so let's start
with basic introduction what this
presentation will be about so we have
large language model for example chat
chat GPT is the famous one and for many
people these models work like some magic
box magic stuff in the input we have
some
instruction this
is written by me simple write a short
poem about this and CH GPT produced this
beautiful poem it's amazing for many
people
but not many people know how the models
works and today I try to explain this
and I hope at the end of presentation
you will never tread this model like
magic box but something rather than
complicated but known
Machinery so first let's start from
basic definition
about language model what is language
modeling and
some this is simple concept about
modeling language this is how NLP
NLP
part many tools like TTS I uses in some
cases some variants of language
models concept about language model
was introduced in 80s years something
like that
and it's task is it's simple it's a
probabilistic model of natural
language it could be any language polish
English Today exist multi language
models but uh language model produces
probabilities of a series of words this
is simple task as a input
we give some words some sentences and
language models produce probabilities of
this words it's that's
simple before artificial neuron networks
language models was built
from many basic statistical tools today
any language model is Neuron
Network and language models is training
in the text
corpora basically is only big data set
of text it could be books
articles any human reing text and today
modern new networks big neural networks
like
Transformers with enough parameters can
work like CH GPT so in the concept CH
GPT models is is is normal language
models but much much bigger so when
language model is large it's a tricky
question and we don't have any precise
definition about when large language
model is large enough so I show you
simple table
of model
sizes at the top we have B base
model is uh not too much but not too big
Transformer architecture model created
by Google the years ago and this kind of
model have
around 100 million
parameters Lama version two this chat
GPT killer made by meta open sourc in
version
two this kind of model have from
7 billions to 65 billions
parameters as you can see it it's it's
much much more than 2 million parameters
and
gpt3 have
around 175 billion
parameters chart GP GPT 4 is enormous is
quite quite bigger but we don't have SI
knowledge about how gp4 works but
GPT gp4 is much bigger T GPT is version
some kind of version about gpt3 it's
called gpt3 .5 turbo something like
that
and it still will be lln or it will be
eln
this is only naming can name whatever
who want uh something clicks tell that
gp4 is couple of smaller models experts
models working
together but open a I don't publish any
more details
about the technical
stuff the C for the Google model to be
so small comparing to the other one
um
today
because bar model was released areer few
few years
ago it could be called prep processor of
GPT
models newer Google model bar is I don't
know precisely how big is B but it's
around size of
gpt3 but I don't know precisely way so
this is diagram shows what language
model
do as I said we input some sentences
could be one sentence all P text and as
output of model we have something magic
value of some fancy function called
perplexity this is function that
measure how good the prediction is and
the relation is that if sentences is
more correct then perplexity of this
sentence is lower so if we dra to the
model not very good sentence we have
weer
perplexity and perplexity
measures perplexity uses distribution
probability distribution generate
generated by the
model so this is simple language
model
so why we use probabilistic
distribution more precise is discreet
probabilistic distribution and if we
think about
language we can assume that each natural
language has some rules grammar
inflection Etc so languages have more
complicated rules other languages are
simple and some words come on acoss
together we have some phrasal verbs and
Etc and if we think about this we
can we can assume
that based on this
facts we we
know that's correct
sentence then if we talking or reading
we can accept that we prob we probably
read correct sentence so we
can we can
describe set of words by its probability
we can assume that random back of wordss
we have lower much lower
probability that's welld designed
sentences so if we analyze analyze big
enough
textor we can create based on this data
set some language
distribution we
can probably we can predict based on
this text corpora What sentences is good
and what sentences will be
bad and language model
learn the text distribution language
distribution based on training data set
and the last point is very
important that every language
model can properly predict only a subset
of language because they models learn
from the text trading data set so if we
ask model
about specific subdomain language like
medical or
Insurance the model that never see this
kind of data
can can make some um useful predictions
so this is very important
note so next question this why language
model have a dictionary because
dictionary is very is very important
part of the model itself so language
model only use known
elements they language model must know
the words that they
predicting
then set of this elements is called
dictionary and
in other words model model learns to map
input words from dictionary to the
feature
space it's because every neuron Network
transform inputs to the numbers precise
Vector of numbers so language model at
they input transform input towards to
the vectors very big
vectors and
and we can if we if
we model try to
model the whole language if we want to
know bigger bigger number of
words the more words model we predict
however there some problems with that
because it's something from MAF called
the curs of
dimensionality with grow of the
dictionary
our neuron Network requires
exponentially more data to
run and this is a huge problem
so let's dive into what is that element
of B it could be work tokens engrams and
I describe this so we
have Poss two possibili we use in the
dictionary small elements like letters
the letter is the smallest number of the
language written language
letter and if we have smaller
dict we but we have much more data to
train the newer Network
because if uh the elements of the
dictionary is small one
letter does not doesn't have any meaning
in the context of language so we must
use much much more
data and letters language
model are not used very
often they they are very fancy and
that's all on the other hand we have we
can use large elements like engrams
engrams is a bag of words
simple and it's easier to learn language
distribution because if you have few
words we have easy to learn about the
language from this words but dict is
much
bigger because what if we can
model unproperly written words we must
use it in dictionary so I dictionary
will grow and grow and grow so we must
find The Sweet Spot from the language
and from the dictionary side so we use
tokens tokens is the sweet spot for
language
modeling and what is token token simple
is
subw it's part of the
world oh we have this
table and the
first we have split text the word second
we have split text the
letters then we have text spitted to
the sub
tokens and on the end of the table we
have example of bam so it's engram in
size of two so we packed our sentences
to the small part of the words
and the best solution for language
modeling
is used to
subwords and this is called
tokenizers tokenization is important
process of preprocessing text this is
the first steps the language model
training and
today we
use most common to algorithm to divide
text
poens and it is B for coding and
sentence piece of course there exist
many others
algorithm but this is the most
common and next chapter is about token
predictions it's called Next token
prediction
so we have our language model our
language model
can describe distribution of wordss in
produce
probabilities it's very fine but pure
probabilities is useful we want to the
model to generate next words to follow
us our prompts and what we must do we
call we use something simple algorithm
called next to
tradiction and this is the main process
for the PEX generation and it's commonly
used by
llms and this algorithm utilizes
probability Maxes by the language
model and the definition of the task is
quite
simple so if you have set of tokens
already produced or these tokens Can
appear as the input so we our goal is to
predict next
token so we can do it by maximizing
conditional
probability of the based from the
previous token So based from the
previous list of tokens we generate next
tokens and this is simple CH rule we can
do it
forever as you can see this is a simple
diagram that shows how language model
produce produce and produce new tokens
so as the input we have our input
sentence it could be prompt or something
like that and every model have some
limits called context
window every model have some constrain
size of the proceed conent context uh
some models have larger some models have
smaller
context but the
models read and extract information from
input sentence then models itself
produce tokens
probabilities and from these
probabilities we
can read and generate next token and
this is done by the coding algorithm
and uh simple algorithm is of course
maximizing probability from each
token and this are the Cod tokens
probability which is on other words list
of possible next
tokens and after the coding process we
have next
token and we add this next token to the
input and we have new input and we go on
for we can go with forever we can
generate token by
token uh answer to the
question given by the
input so this is example of the
coding and we start from prompt are you
hry and first we will be called I
and you can see Pro the numbers of
probabilities of existing of the next
tokens as I
can speak earlier we have many others
algorithm the
code to
to this is algorith with
temperature yes every step the whole di
is used
to
yes yes in common pattern is to use to
whole dictionary and more precisely this
distribution of words is distribution
from dictionary words so probabilities
from all tokens from dictionary is some
to one like probabilities should do but
actually in mod GPT models you also have
Dynamic soft Mar so you only use a part
of the Diary prediction so the training
process is
faster yeah yes of course exist some
variance of
optimization and this is example of the
coding with
temperature and
this make add some noise to the
output because
we pick not often we be the most
probability word but the
mo one of the top probability and this
add some noise the output and some
Randomness because sometimes we want at
model will produce out correct output
but with some
randoms and this is the simplest way to
add some kind of Randomness to the outut
so we proceed talken by to
for example of course this is example
and I use for because words are easier
to
read so step by step we decoding and
asking model about new tokens
and we
have complete answer I would eat
something but the next question is how
we stop the generation yes question so
talk about no is this the temperature or
is it the
noise temperature not the first most
work is always
CH uh this is only simplify example it's
plenty of algorithm that add noise uh
it's temperature it's top K top P
parameters but this is the simplest way
to show that we not always choose the
the most probability one this is the
some
simplification and next question is how
we control the generation process
because we sometimes we want to stop the
generation how we tell the model that
stop this is enough we can of course
Force the model to always generate for
example 500 tokens or
generate maximum number of compx window
but this is not very useful we want to
model to that that model somehow know
that when when he should stop so we add
the dictionary control tokens this is
the easiest way we have for example
begin of sequence token and end of
sequence
token and we learn
model that when
he should end the generation so at the
beginning of the sentence we always add
the BOS
token begin of sequence at the end we
add end of sequence token and to the
training
process the model learn when it should
stop the generation and this the
simplest way to to generate
text
so now I show you the basic steps to
train Pro langu large language model
from
scratch and the first step is to prepare
enormous amount of text because our
model is very large billions of
parameters we must prepare lots of text
to fit the model because if the model
grow we need more more data to train to
train the
model so if we need more data we must
use lots of gpus so we must rent a GPU
cluster and this model can train from
scratch for weeks months it took took
very long because we create from this
text
books we call it
self-supervised and we must create
training samples for next token
prediction and what is the sample so we
create we our model want to know the
language the learn the language so we
must create many examples from each
sentences we
create basic engrams as the input and
targets will be the next tokens
so as you can see we from one sentence
create few
example we can from one from one bunch
of text we can create dozens of examples
because we must Feit the context window
so we have exponentially more
examples created from simple short text
as you can see this create
enormous data set so that's why the
language model training from scratch
took very long
time so next next step it's called find
unique it's more fun it's more enjoyable
and we at the voice lab focus on fine
tuning the large language
models so what's the find you
uni so that we use pre-rain models we
call it prain models because training
model from scratch is not funny we don't
have resources we don't have time we
don't have enough GPU
Powers so we start from hugging hugging
face
repository they are plenty open source
models I I call area we use for example
Lama from meta
and we can download this model and start
our own
experiment so we call it precise
instruction fine
tuning because pre-train large model
large language model can predict
probability of the input
sentences he is doing very well he can
generate simple
text he also so have some kind of
knowledge learn from the Lang learn from
the data set he have some knowledge
about language
itself weights weight model weights
contains some
information
but this model cannot follow user
instruction if we test row find uh row
large language model for example low L
row
Lama that model can generate some simple
talks but cannot follow our instruction
we want that our model follow user
prompts instruction and generate
whatever we want so we call must fun
it's called instruction F
tuning the main goal of llm is I said
earlier follow the user in instruction
so user interact with model by chatting
for example we have chat GPT demo and we
can chat with
him and uh this is the next step of
training and we must train on
instruction data set and instruction
fine tuning will teach our model how to
follow the user prompts how
to generate what want and this is the
most important step in evolution process
of language modeling because we change
from Simple Text distribution language
distribution and we jump to the
intelligent assistant then can
understand what we want and
generate whatever you want in
simplication in some
simplification so this is the most
crucial step for our
proceeding
and what is
instruction definition of the
instruction is very
simple it is some kind of prompt as the
input and it could be task for
extracting generating calculating it
will be everything and the second part
of the instruction is the correct output
of the
model so if we have
example of please that calculate the
area of the
square rectangle 4 by five and the model
should answer the that is
20 and this Bunch set of instruction is
instruction data and funny is the on the
low level the training of the language
model is the same it's still on the low
level is next token
prodution but in the our
abstraction you can call it new
abstraction layer We Are One Step Above
and this is not simple text but
instruction and
outputs and we must prepare many many of
instruction and it's some problem with
this data
set uh
because but we have some fine
information fine tuning on instruction
requires less GPU because we have small
data
set but and uh for example we can f tune
on few
gpus the exist algorithm that optimize
training or training some parts of model
so we can train at home or small
business or rent few gpus for few days
few
weeks but it's one
problem creating of these data
sets the r language model was trained on
the pure text pure corpora we download
the Wikipedia we scan the books and we
have data set but we with instruction we
must prepare instructions and
outputs and data preparation is
challenging
problem it's all whole data science in
the this is the most time
consuming preparation
correcting and checking the data sets we
spend all these weeks months
and of course data collection and
annotation because we call this process
annotation is expensive in time and
Human Resources so on the one hand we
need less compute power but other the
hand we need more human manually
work and let's dive into these data sets
because we use very often open source
data sets because we don't have an
efficient number of humans to create
data sets so we use internet and
download Open Source because open source
is
fine but we have some problems
because large language
models are sensitive to bias in data any
small perturbation
[Music]
can have influence negative influence or
our model
performance I show you few examples
but I think every data scientist know
that open source
data cannot be trusted we must always
check everything because we have
unexpected behavior of
models so as example I show you this is
from
alaka alpaka data
set and we find that data set contains
some
mistake
like and the model from this can learn
nothing and if we
have I say
around 100
instructions and few hundred will be
this kind of nothing class our
model
can can predicts garbage so we must
check and correct every every this kind
of
mistake gold golden rule is we want less
data but with high higher quality
quality over numbers
it's a good point so this is another
example of incorrect
instruction uh sometimes in open data
sets exist nonsense
instructions I don't know why
but but we must correct it so if we work
on the TRU the ma the main part of the
production process was to correct and
find correct is easy but we must find
these mistakes for example ear version
of our
model if the model don't know the
answer the true
generate that he cannot translate it to
other language and we
think why why if we TR does not know the
answer then ask for translation do not
make sense and we find some data set
from open
source that these data sets contains
lots of misle misannotated translation
tasks and our Tru was biased on this
data we find it after two weeks or
free so this is hell of
data so do you have any questions yeah
um can you use stronger model to create
training data
set yes this is quite new approach it's
use gp4 because gp4 is the
best and on the other hand it's good
idea to use something better but
always you must remember that every
model have some bias
some sometimes gp4 can produce not the
best output we always must checking the
answers of course uh use stronger model
speed up the process but we never tread
the
the GPT for as the absolute and so what
if open
AI want to produce better model than
gp4 creating data to train better model
than gp4 based on gp4 output could be
misleading
yeah polish yes we create we have our
own data sets conversation data sets we
create data sets
from internet we
create our
own polish data sets of instruction and
we some add some we we
also change some data sets existing we
call convert from one tasks like
translations data sets or sentiment uh
to the instruction data
sets so mod like M language langu so how
do you make
that we always add uh some general data
sets uh it's true that if
we train model on small domain data set
the model could forget information from
previous trainings so we always add
general purpose data sets and we during
training we often check the model
performance so we know exactly when the
model start to degradate
dating
and that's
it last
question but you use original Lama
English toer yeah yes yes so we can code
through Polish language model if we use
original English to uh llama uses
multilanguage tokenizers llama itself is
multi language it's some part of Polish
data but I think
80 to 90% of data is English R Lama can
produce Polish language but some often
the model makes
mistakes because because Rama
uses I think sentence piece and the
tokens is more General D wordss and the
tokenizer is multil language because
they use tokens from every language they
always they
add I think the Chinese and the special
tokens they
are right so let's thank for the
[Applause]
presentation so thank you and join our
hugging pH voice hugging pH you can join
our Linkin
and you can try our
true our fancy little
robot we'll make two three minutes of
break just to switch for the second
presentation so don't go
[Music]
anywhere
okay
that might be a good
idea
[Music]
spe
right so please take your
seats and uh vote for Ado uh we have
kich and wki from snow
snowflake uh they will present quite a
lot of insights from the snowflake
itself regarding data science data
engineering uh so let's welcome them
with a round of
applause he everyone thanks for having
us and and hosting us here especially we
are not from three City so it's always a
nice reason to visit you It's a very
beautiful city uh my name is p with me
there is w we represent a company that
is called
snowflake uh I think it was not
intentional but the topic of our
collection somewhat connects with the
first one that we had about uh LMS in
general because we focus more on the
real cost can you hear me in the back
should I speak louder okay uh we try to
focus today on the part of a data
science work that is generally a whole
cost of working on not very scalable
environments and working on large data
sets feature engineering things you were
talking about so uh we will do a
helicopter review through a platform
that will be very fast I'll try to uh
answer a question I'm stating by myself
why the platform should be used like
ours and then we will do a short demo of
data science capabilities and ukash will
deliver this because he's much smarter
guy than I am and generally I I would
start with a job because I'm always
stressed when I'm speaking publicly so
when I'm interacting with LM I'm usually
very polite in case they go full Skynet
so it's a recommendation for all of you
it's it's good to say please when you
speak with Chad G or something
else uh so generally what is snowflake
we are a commercial product and and this
is something I need to state right away
we're not an open source there was a
bunch of uh Engineers that was working
for Oracle there was a Polish PhD that
was working on Vector engines and back
in 2012 they tried to solve a problem of
a very large scale not only scale of
data but also scale of performance which
means if you're in on premise forever
you work with Solutions like ratas
oracles at the time they were the right
solution also but all of these platforms
were struggling with one thing generally
it's not easy to scale them so the idea
was to take the best practices of what
they learned in on premise move it to
the cloud and start to use advantages of
the cloud
like basically
unlimited capacity of virtual machines
regardless if you go with AIA with with
AWS or with Google as much of virtual
machines they're having it would be cool
to consume them and consume them
immediately for the purpose of large
analytics or maybe purpose of large data
science engineer Dee me uh the similar
Paradigm connects to uh storage
regardless how much capacity or how much
of data you have you would like to scale
elastically with your St storage and and
back in the days these days basically
because this is summer between 2005 and
2012 we don't talk about these ones
because it's already a legacy but we're
under the 3ev Paradigm so velocity
variety volume so a lot a lot of
different data different
languages uh no common solution to
tackle all these problems like payers we
go scale easily have a lot of storage so
these guys came up with the idea to
build one platform uh that should be
able to tackle all of those and around
2015 there was not many platforms like
that big quer was entering the market
and they were spinning up through was
asked and and everything was a bit
behind and they came up with the idea I
will be going very fast with because
there is a lot of marketing BL and I
want to avoid this but generally the
idea
is regardless what kind of data you have
structured unstructured
Json par
csvs uh Audi files whatever you would
like to store them within one single
platform why because of governance uh
because of bias because of fair data
it's easier to track changes it's easier
to assign permissions it's easier if you
store them within one place and all of
the data can be interconnected can be
joined so if you if you work with time
series data you would like to connect it
with structured data if you work with
unstructured data you would like to have
have analy immediate access to metadata
extracted out of those so that was the
idea uh behind the platform from
2015 it evolved a lot into different
directions that just Warehouse that was
the initial case because these guys that
were building the platform were uh
people that were building Legacy
warehouses so from
the workload as they are calling it a
warehouse they moveed more into
engineering
providing uh
orchestration automations stor
procedures udfs bring your models to the
platform make it a part of data
pipelines uh they start to build a
seamless architecture that would be
available on all of the clouds looks the
same and generally the idea was to
provide all kind of languages for the
users because users are not the same
there are SQL users there are are more
advanced users that write in ad that
writes in Python that use Java
connectors that create
applications and we would like to serve
them all why because their data is
actually in the platform because this
was the whole idea so if you have all
data within the one place you would like
to also serve all kind of users you have
within your company and this was the
idea
of what can we build how this was built
it's a concept that I think whoever
works with software NOS as 3 TI
architecture we use something similar so
generally if you think about snowflake
you see it as a single sus solution so
you don't manage it there is a web page
you enter the web page you see your
databases you can connect to the URL
with your Jupiter with your D whatever
you are using it's dedicated for you it
uses an csql it uses python so as you
would work with transactional data as
you would work with data frames you
actually interact with the data that is
within the platform that ISU Ed in the
schemas databases things you
know now when you're interacting with
the platform this goes to the top layer
which I'll be not focusing today because
it's something we called uh Services
layer so it's the brain of the platform
this is where we are compiling the your
python your SQL into to see this is
where metadata is automatically stored
so you put data in we collect
automatically data this is also kind of
a movement
where the the Creator
uh came to sensus saying okay actually
the idea of vacuuming data collecting
statistics putting indexes partitioning
data is not so cool maybe Engineers are
liking it but business doesn't like it
because it inures a cost someone needs
to do it and instead of focusing on
training models tuning models deploying
models to production people are spending
times or on things that are unrelevant
from business perspective having an
index is not relevant
having a Insight or outcome of a qu is
relevant how fast why what can we do
with it so they compile a lot of
different stuff within the first layer
uh just to autom automate all of these
operations like backups like indexes
like statistics like compression like
encryption so whatever comes in
automatically goes through an engine
that makes it more digestible from
Snowflake uh what happens beneath in
these two layers is much more important
the first one and I starts from the
bottom is the storage layer and while I
think that's relevant for uh data
science and what ukash will be showing
you because on this layer it's where the
scalability of the platform takes place
so why data is U touched fast why can be
modified fast why feature engineering on
that platform Works how this interact
with uh data science so if you think
about General data science within its
Paradigm usually you would either works
on a very large clusters either in the
cloud or on PR or in most of the cases
you would be part of something that's
called Shadow it you have your laptop
you have your virtual machines you take
your data in unauthorized way you load
it to the memory of your laptop you try
to do something with it and then maybe
store the results back within the
repository so quite often the data as
you have it is either not accessible to
you as a scientist or an engineer who is
the scientist
here one two three four five who's the
engineer and five hidden probably more
who is the
analyst one who else do we have here
two data architect who
else what other roles we have because we
have like 30 people and I 10 people
raised their hands so we have some other
roles here hidden roles hidden R theying
working on Shadow
PMS architects
who students students okay it's
generally so so whom of you Works in
Enterprises not in startups but in in
places where you have some governance
rules in
place okay we have around 10 people
and if you work on a consumer side how
much time it takes for you to get the
data you need actually so you're
performing either received a request to
build a report or you have hypothesis
you need to validate or you want to do a
self-service and create a schema for you
how much time it takes
usually depends on the
project
average you don't have it on your laptop
I need to add that's sure that's sure
days hours weeks six months maybe
more so if we if we speak with banks
because sometimes we speak with banks
here a usual project where you have uh
something like selfservice sandbox for a
consumer may take up to six months which
means I received a hypothesis I
identified where is my data I need to
reach out to the owners of the data and
then I reach out knowing the owners and
having permission to it to deliver that
data for me so it's convoluted it's
heavy it's complex it's not easy to get
those so if you have everything stored
within one place in format there is
micro partition it so very small files
that are invisible for you but allow
huge concurrency and you have airb or
governance rules access rules in place
you have some kind of Enterprise catalog
it's very easy to reduce the time from
months to maybe weeks it really depends
on the culture we may say in seconds but
usually this doesn't happen because
there tickets just ID people need need
to work so these process always stay but
the time can be reduced because
everything is one place when you touch
the data you touch it fast and now once
you store it in the platform you name it
as database table you put it into
schemas everything is there you have
airb rules you know what is what you
have dictionaries not dictionaries like
you mentioned it but business
dictionaries glossaries things that
allow you to work with the data you need
power to work with the data so imagine
you're taking your laptop or your
clusters and you assign to each of your
users a cluster individually and this
cluster can be deployed within seconds
milliseconds with the size you need so
if you work with petabytes of data you
may have cluster of 500 virtual machines
if you work with 100 million rows you
may have just one virtual machine and
that deployment happens in seconds and
that deployment for each one of the
users can can be individualized so
regarding what workload they're touching
what they are working with each one of
them can have a different size
cluster and can be isolated from other
users which is also kind of a problem
that that was happening quite often you
know premises where the evolution was
happening and this was like a second
wave of data warehousing Evolution
meaning even if you buy a large box
framework whatever uh you have
a rack with size of the TR you are still
limited by the size of the TR right if
you have use cases that you are piling
up within the Trum as we are having the
seats here you may have as many people
theoretically as you have
seats right so you may say that I'm
standing if we have no one concerned but
I assume everyone understands if we
assume that we want to put analyst on
one side they just SES on the other side
and do some kind of
segregation to allow some workloads to
run faster than the others we are still
limited by what by the size of the tone
and the number of seats right yeah have
one confirmation thank you sir but then
we can make a data science Meetup and we
need to kick all the data Engineers out
right for example but the idea is we
don't want that we don't want to be
limited by the size of the single room
so we isolate compute from compute and
compute from Storage meaning if you
store everything it may exist without
any compu the data but also if you
bundle up all of the workloads you may
isolate one work from another and aze it
right power so platform like this can
scale in multiple axises why it's
relevant because for data sciences that
wuk will show later it's very important
to give that one person ability to scale
train do feature engineering do data
engineering joining the data without
impacting for example bu business so if
we would like him to work on a large
data set we would tell him go to the
other room take all your belongings take
your tools and don't don't interact with
anyone else because the other ones here
are representing business that needs to
run constantly without the stop you
cannot take their seeds because we have
exactly as many users as we have seats
so we have the dedicated room for you to
do your experiments and that's the whole
idea so he can do whatever he needs if
he needs bigger room he goes to an admin
and admin says yeah we have a larger
room for you go there one foror higher
or whatever so the platform scales by
deploying multiple compute clusters each
cluster dedicated for particular
workloads as we call them but also
giving you possibility to decide if you
want to have one seat or 500 seats per
each query or per each task train model
on 200 virtual machines to feature Eng
engineer on 100 and do andas just on one
because this is the need of that moment
I don't want to be limited by that room
or be enforced to always be in the room
that has a size like this one why
because when I work from 8 to 12 I do
trivial things and one vir machine is
cheaper and better for me between 1210
and 125 I'm training a model and I need
512 for that period of 5 minutes why not
maybe this is your need and the idea is
to allow this and allow users to
constantly scale up and down where they
need because your workloads are heavy
nature that
changes today is not the same as for
tomorrow why because you have more data
possibly maybe there were
changes and aside of this one there's
also another type of scalability which
is out meaning higher concurrency but
it's not relevant today so the platform
is made out of brain of compute where
you decide who queries what how fast
what is the SL we are agreeing and
general storage uh General storage and
this will be a kind of a snooze as for
you maybe not relevant but uh when we
work with the table to make the table
accessible because also data expands
like we talk about 3v what you have
today is different than what you had
yesterday and maybe different what you
will have in one hour and tables are
shrinking and expanding so to keep track
generally of performance and make the
performance consistent snowflake had to
find a way how to make it scalable for
tables not for computer so if we have a
table with a size of uh 100 megabytes
and we have a table with size of one one
terabyte
or 100 gigs or one petabyte how to make
performance the same between the sizes
because something needs to touch that
data and work with it so the option to
keep performance in line was to divide
the table in a very small chunks files
are 16 megabytes of size and each of
those files when it when you load the
data is created automatically so this
represent rows from one to five this
from five to 10 105 and of course with
the size of the table number of those
micro partitions is increasing because
more files more more data more rows more
micro partitions but the engine is smart
enough to know which mic partitions it
should pick when you're asking a qu when
you do feature engineering when you do
selects when you do do engine decides oh
you did a wear that has the IND this of
from now to 7 Days in the past or maybe
where the customer ID is something so in
this case engine
says bypass micro partition 57 12
because microp partition two and three
are having your data so it makes the
performance consistent and it basically
tricks the platform to use something
that would be similar to index
but it doesn't have to be kept it
doesn't have to be maintained it happens
automatically incrementally whenever the
data comes in so it's a very cheap way
of uh storing the data and keeping the
performance and why it's
relevant because when you are touching
the data you are doing it concurrently
for data scientists it's very relevant
to pick a lot of data concurrently and
not one file at a time not cize your
operation but do a lot of stuff in
concurrent because it's cheaper and
faster uh what kind of Statistics are
exposed Min Maxes distin uh cardinality
things like that so the platform is
always aware what in microp partition or
in your table microp partitions are
invisible for users it's just the way
how we store files for your tables you
see tables you work with tables but
underneath this is uh how it's working
this is the source um I'll skip pruning
because I mention it um virtual
warehouses they will be relevant here
because this is this is how you interact
with your data so every user uh whenever
it runs whenever he she runs a query the
sides what's the context for a query and
context represents what are my
permissions and what kind of clusters I
will use for that query is it extra
small cluster meaning the smallest one
medium that's four times bigger large
eight time Biggers or maybe it has 512
machines and generally we use a naming
of t-shirts so it starts with extra
small small medium large and so on
what's underneath is not relevant what
is relevant is that extra small means
one virtual machine small two for8 and
so on and it equals
power um when the query comes in usually
you would use either interactive UI some
kind of a client maybe application
powerbi Jupiter notebook um I'm not sure
what you're working with Deb maons
Studio code virtual Studio Jango
whatever you're going to use use this
interacts with the platform using common
connectors stbc orbc rest
underneath uh when these connectors when
you are performing the job they are
wrapped into the context saying what's
my name what's my password what is my
role so current permissions what kind of
or what's the name of an object I like
to touch so uh database schema table do
I wanted to join and what is the
warehouse so the computer I'll be
running for that query which means that
you can dynamic either rescale those
clusters if you want or switch between
them because there are different uh
patterns depending on what you need yeah
in in Snowflake when we are talking
about virtual warehouses we are talking
about Computing clusters this is the
naming that we have so when P says
Warehouse yeah sorry think about compute
cluster two servers that is doing the
calculation and I will explain in a
second what does it means so generally
you use you use connectors you send the
query query goes to the service layer
service layer evaluates did I reply to
that query in the last 24 hours did the
data change underneath I need to check
the statistics if statistics for that
table are the same or for the micro
partition he tries to touch all the same
I don't need to answer the qu again in
return I will give you something from my
cash and say dude this was your query in
last 24 hours data is the same job ask
me again like have it for free so the
platform Returns the cash for free in
situations where the data didn't change
when the data change and has been
compiled into
C it hits something we call virtual
Warehouse compute or a cluster that has
a particular size of virtual machines
underneath and you don't manage that you
just see a a virtual machine called
Finance VM or whatever and underneath
there is a lot of nodes and that VM
performs for you a job select on your
table with in the end pick those micro
partitions in parall
what's the advantage of using it is that
the bigger Warehouse you have the
bigger concurrency and parallelity of
these processes you are having imagine
you are not working with the same data
as um or you are working on the same
table as your peers you have 65 people
touching the same table now if you would
work with the traditional environment we
go to the same issue which is size of
the room and how much you can squeeze
but if you can multiply the rooms or
streamate life you may have much more
recipients of the same data so what
happens here where is come to the
platform in parallel because you have 60
p the company hires thousands of people
how large is your company 50 people how
many
analysts maybe three three scientists no
okay so imagine we have 3D not three
which would mean that one extra small
may not is sufficient for them and some
of them are working on the data that
represents sales the the other ones are
working on the data that represents
marketing why not divide them and and
dedicate them their own power and size
so when you define context context is
virtual warehouses warehouses decide
which microp partitions they should pick
for the query and how to do it in a
scalable way if the engine decides that
warehouse
the microp partitions change and there
are new
statistics it will just pick the right
ones as you see the ones that were
deprecated or removed and new ones are
pulled from the storage layer in a very
fast way now the whole idea just to
repeat it again store everything in one
place all kinds of data and have
unlimited power for your operations
engineering training SQL analyzes
connecting with power Pi these people
don't inter interact with each other
however they are working on the same
data which means there needs to be some
kind of isolation to give all of them
the SLA they need how you can interact
in many different ways basically every
connector that is on the market is
available uh and if there are no
connectors you can compile them into
containers and throw them into the
platform and run them as
udfs which means that your logic can be
nested within the platform you can bring
your libraries and run it as a part of a
regular SQL because not everyone is data
scientist or model developer or you can
like run large language models as well
right we had a yes recent meet on the
recent Meetup we were presenting
something like that so we can have own
CH gbt inside you may bring uh hugging
face or whatever comes to the platform
and execute it in a way of interacting
as a consumer so you have your model
nested as a UDF you run SQL and you
predict something linear regression or
whatever you need or maybe analyze the
sentiment and context of phrases words
uh you have unstructured data that would
be
chatboard uh recording so what the
chatbot says it's stored as a varar or
maybe as a Json and then use the models
to extract the sentiment using SQL you
don't need to be a developer what kind
of value it gives to you it gives a huge
value for marketing or for support
people to know to whom reach out if
you're a game
developer and you are releasing a new
version of your game to your mobile and
you're collecting events for every
second and these events are like Json
and they represent some kind of feedback
where the error happens like the game
crashes there is popup saying we just
found an issue there's a bug write
something to the developers developers
can use the models inside of the
platform to bring SQL outcomes so count
how many
uh occurrences of something like crash
when um I don't know I pick and SW this
is a tri example but represents
generally in this case so uh so this is
it LMS within the SQL are having very
are very hot right now the the market is
going crazy to do something with them
the idea of having LMS in data
warehousing classrooms is not that clear
because there are problems of
uh who owns the code who is responsible
for mistakes who is responsible for ret
trining the models and so on it's not so
easy
but
generally uh this is something we see as
a wave coming in uh we didn't see it
production life heavy yet however we've
seen for example uh llms models so large
language model being executed in retail
where people from business are writing
in the human language and in the end the
SQL code is created and and the B
basically replies with the outcomes for
a human language that represents
SQL
Sol so snowflake is database right or or
multiple databases so this is one of the
languages you can use to
interact so when you have and we will be
speaking this in a second we will talk
about one of the features that is very
relevant for the platform may be
relevant for you also uh let me find the
right slide other
slides so what we are talking about is
just the subset of the platform while
the platform is much bigger it's one
platform and all of these are
representing features uh we will be
talking about a feature called snow park
and snow park represents it's an
umbrella there it represents logic
protein so like LMS en closed as udfs
but it also allows you to interact using
python or Java but generally what
happens when you interact using
functional languages not declarative
language which is because SQL is
declarative python is not is that
underneath we will translate your python
code if it's not bundled as a procedure
or function into SQL why we are doing
this because we found a very optimal way
of running something called MPP massive
parallel processing and using parallel
number of virtual machines to pick up a
parallel number of micro partitions so
it goes back to the early slide
so you interact using uh python
libraries you writing functions but you
send the code to the platform platform
picks your Python and in the back end
service layer will convert it to SQL you
don't see it but it's very fast and it's
a very cheap way for us of picking that
data and and converting it it's a way of
bringing your code to the data not the
opposite so bringing your data to your
laptops and doing something in your
memory we do it the oppositely why
because it's much easier for you to work
if you have access to Unlimited
Performance than to bring large data
sets to your local environment which on
one hand violates the security and
governance on the other hand is limited
to the size of the room again so we try
to avoid this by giving you if you
decided right now I need 64 terabytes of
memory it's possible by sending the code
to the platform not sending the data
back to your environment was there a
question or you were just fxing okay
fine uh I think I shouldn't go deeper
because I see it's very late and and
people are already smoothing so if you
have any questions regarding what we
will talk
about uh please do ask if not I will
give ukas time to execute the demo and
maybe seeing
this in live demo will give you more
understanding of what we are talking
about
generally the way of bringing your Cod
the platform is possible by using that
umbrella called snowbar and it allows
you to compile either your models your
python pipelines into UDF or storage
procedures and execute it within the
platform using SQL or python or whatever
you
like um snow park I was mentioning is
doing two things one you work with data
frames but in the back we translated to
SQL you don't know but it's the the
compatibility between the data frame
appy uh Scala Java data frames or python
is like 90% so you write functions and
engine knows what to do and the other
thing that snark does it allows you to
take your code bundle it up into a
function or St procedure and execute it
in the platform as it is in the sandbox
environment so these things are not
translated to SQL these things are so if
you bring us your model and you bundle
it as a file we will execute it as this
but if you write a data frame
a query we will convert it in the back
into
SQL uh I think I will hand it back I
will cover them L do some
exercises Cahoots okay
so so there is a there is a lot of
things in snow park umbrella term so I
will be jumping into into the demo I
will present you how you can work with
snowflake using python in particular but
you can also use Java and Scala you can
use SQL it's a natural language for
snowflake uh so let me just jump in as
later on we have a really nice
architecture that we haven't covered
this is the news from the like yesterday
that's snowflake intention to buy Ponder
who is also responsible for modin so
basically it's a I would say modin is
the uh pandas comp pandas
compatible framework that gives you the
ability to work on multiple CPUs on on
the machine so it's it gives you much a
lot of speed on on the other way is
something like the P we there something
that will provide this Panda API to
different different engines so this is
this is quite new and quite fresh I
would say
okay uh regarding the
demo uh before I jump in maybe I will
just summarize something that the things
that said uh with a short short demo of
the snowflake itself so here you can see
one of the uis like mentioned that you
can work with Visual Studio code with
Jupiter's notebook DB Weaver any type of
tool that use jdbc orbc rest and so on
but here I'm using the out of the box UI
that snowflakes provides which is called
snowside I once told the story about
this scaling up and down and I get the
question okay we know what the cloud is
so you probably know it as well but the
key piece over here is that you really
don't need to maintain it and I will
just show you how you easily can create
virtual Warehouse so this is this
Computing engine that P set so to create
virtual engine you just need to type a
name and press create virtual warehouse
and right now you it's already started
so it's extra small virtual warehouse
and you can just WR right now start
writing SQL queries if this is not
enough you can just size it to extra
large right and it's right now it's
extra large you can start working on
extra large so there is no like putting
the machine down waiting five minutes
put turning in on on selecting the
machines selecting the high ability
selecting the storage and so on it's it
just works what just happened so with
that simple operation we just reiz from
one virtual machine to 16 in the back
and and the time it takes like seconds
and also what you see on the uh on on on
on the screen is the name of a compute
clusters to easily identify them because
each user needs a context so needs to
know with what he works or she you have
a size that represents amount of power
and you have status meaning am I running
or am I sleeping the ones that are not
in used are automatically going to sleep
the one that are used are automatically
waken up and and are awaken just your
job and then they will go again to sleep
if they are not needed yeah how to
control costs that easy to that's uh
airbu so everything is governed you may
decide who has access to which one of
the computer clusters you may a you may
not B but you may C you might scale or
you you don't you might not can scale or
not and and there's easy way of tracking
back the C so if you work in Enterprise
and you have chargebacks you can hack
operations per virtual Warehouse to
easily identify who was running the cost
on those and we also have the Autos
suspend mode so it's automatically it's
you see it's was default five minutes
you can change it to one minute
snowflake is built per second so if you
put the calculation in and and snowflake
will do the calculation in 2 minutes 15
seconds then you can suspend it and you
can pay for 2 minutes 15 seconds and in
that two minutes 15 seconds there can be
n a huge number of queries there is a
concurrency you can you can do snowflake
can run multiple queries at the same
time we are talk thinking about a but
you can it's a default option but you
can change it depend on if the query is
light or heavy you can change it to 20
or 30 and if there will be more you can
also use this multic claster feature so
it's a scale out which P was covering a
little bit so as you can see the the
form to create and to manage it's simple
you just want the size want the
warehouse and that's it and you can just
go to the worksheets and go to the some
kind of SQL let me just find you don't
need to also always work with the UI if
you do things programmatically
from code everything is configured as an
SQL so creating a warehouse is a comment
like create warehouse warehouse type
extra small name and that's it exactly
you everything that I clicked you can
write in SQL so if you want to create
the virtual Warehouse just can execute
the command and that's it regarding the
resizing uh it's also like alter
warehouse It's large right now it will
execute this query really fast and then
you can just alter it to extra small
when it's finished or and then you can
or you can suspend it so it's a SQL
based database so also it follows all
the paradigms of terraforming uh boiler
plating environments so if you have cicd
and you push down the code basically
everything can be configured externally
so we can send the code to the platform
to be executed and attach different
processes to it for example service now
or whatever company is using yes and
this is like so we work like we look
like the typical database so you have
databases you have the schemas you have
the tables views and so on and and you
can and the storage is completely
separated from the computer so if I want
to analyze shift sale like only for the
certain country or the certain city I
don't need the really large Computing
cluster to do the any type of
calculation so I can work with extra
small but when I need to do the create
the model for the whole data set
probably the ex small will be too too
small so I I need to scale it up and
scaling up and down doesn't create any
outages so basically you can scale up
all the queries will finish on the extra
small and all new will come to the extra
large and then you can scale it down and
everything like will be still running
and all then you will be go go to extra
small so no outages snowflake is is
automatically in free of ability zones
so it's perfectly safe we have 90 days
time travel so the data is backed up so
basically you low put the data and and
you just just start working with it and
and that's it but this is like to sum up
what spot was saying so what I want to
show you is how you can interact with
with snowflake using Python and exactly
this snow park which which we presented
so I will be working on the tasty on the
Tasty Bites data so Tasty Bites is a uh
Global Food track Network they are
selling food using foot tracks they have
couple of issues I don't want to really
go into the scenario but we will be
talking about selling food from the food
tracks and they are located in many
different countries including Poland in
warso in K Unfortunately they are think
they are thinking
about maybe it will be it it come it
will come soon what I will be doing I be
I will be using the snow park one-onone
for data science so snowflake creates
something that is called quick starts so
it's really nice uh and free repository
of of tutorials when you go to the mind
particular one so I have tasty
I'm I'm using this one so you can go you
have you have information how to create
Conta environment you you will get the
predefined Jupiter notebook uh page
where where you can run those particular
statements as as I I'm doing I tweaked
it a little bit I'm added some some
extra stuff but basic basically if you
want to learn snowflake or check some
kind of feature how to do streaming in
Snowflake you can go here find the
particular uh and correct uh quick start
and just start working with snowflake
you can create your own snowflake
account it's free we snowflake gives you
$400 worth of credits and you can create
your account and start working with the
data anything everyone can create a
trial for free you just need your email
you don't need to provide your credit
card or anything similar and then if
you're working on open data sets Noma or
whatever comes to your mind and you want
to train use trial test how it works
like and you can create multiple
accounts using the same email address so
you don't need to change that never we
of course don't recommend it
forbidden people that
do employees who who talk about
it okay so I will focusing on the on the
snow park and I will be doing two things
first I will be do I will be doing a
little bit of feature engineering so I
will create the data frame with it do
some filtering aggregation and so on
just to show you that it works exactly
like P spark data like ppar data frames
Works basically F said 90 I heard about
95 98% of compatibility percentage of
compatibility so basically you can
change the import p park to import snow
park and probably it will work but on
theow on snowflake on snowflake clusters
not on spark clusters the idea is here
to do the push down so the company is
being B moding uh what you do in Python
is generally using the lazy method
meaning I'm pushing all the work to
platform platform executes the work for
me and I'm just returning the results
for myself to do plots or things like
that so push down is very important uh
contest yeah second thing that I will be
doing I will be registering model and
I'll
be running that training that model on
snowflake virtual virtual
Warehouse uh using the store procedure
and then I will create the userdefined
function using the trained model to
execute it as a function inside SQL uh
statement so this is the main idea so
what you can do actually in Snowflake
you can do the whole analytical life
cycle so you can prepare transform data
using data frames you can train so this
fit you can do the fitting on snowflake
then we are working this private preview
element uh but I hope soon it will be
released to public preview so we will
have the model registry where you can
register it right now you can just save
it and store it and uh reuse it uh and
you can declare UDF and start start
doing the inference you can just
basically score score your data using
that that model and create the
prediction data set and this is
everything you can do using python uh
language we have some additional
libraries like ml modeling ml modeling
is just a wrapper for uh couple of uh
dat machine learning libraries like
psyit learn boost and I think one
more uh but probably it will be
expanding uh so what ml modeling will be
doing is basically it gives you the
ability to train the model a little bit
easier so you don't need to provide a
lot of code we simplify that and we also
uh changed a little bit of Prep Prep
processing so we also can uh do the MPP
processing for it because it is also
converted it can be also converted to
SQL like one hot encoder for example so
this will be automatic converted to SQL
so you can use this all extra large
cluster to to run the this this
transformation much faster than on a
single
machine uh okay so let me maybe jump to
the demo just to present you uh
something uh before the times run up
runs
up okay so first of all to start working
with python you need to have your own
environment uh I'm using uh uh I'm using
cond environment and creating my own P
Snow Park 2 environment with couple of
libraries so first of all I need to
import them so I will be using pandas
plotly Json and snow park snow park just
to have a session some functions and
window function so first of all I need
to import it let me try
maybe enlarge it a little
bit then I need to log to snowflake I
have multiactor out authentication so I
need to confirm what he's doing right
now is the context I was mentioning I
think what you defined so username and
password it's obvious but what are my
permissions is the role and which
compute cluster I'm using right now
which is telling the operation how much
how many nodes you will receed for that
query or the next where or next
operations yeah this is optional because
each user can have default role and
default warehouse but just to make it
super clear I'm typing it uh explicitly
uh in in the in the in the code so first
of all I need to create data frame so
it's a it's really simple I just create
a session table session is already
established using those credentials I'm
using the table and specifying the table
that I want to load to snow snow park
data frame and snow data frame are lazy
so basically they are not executed until
you will explicit ask show me the data
in my environment so when I will create
it you run this show then of course the
the data frame itself will be executed
on the snowflake side and will pass me
the only the results so right now when I
go to the uh my snowflake environment to
the
activity I will refresh it so you will
see this particular query was executed
from the Jupiter from my visual studio
code and of course you can do check you
check the whole Query profile for
example check how it works how the
pruning look like so I scanned only one
micro partition out of two micro
partition which proos mentioned and so
on so everything here is executed on the
snowflake when you ask for it as you see
here he's running a table function in
one of the blocks above while while
snowflake was seeing it as a SQL code so
he had select star from something is
basically the function underne so now
it's a little so something that some of
you who who wor worked on with ppar may
may it might may seem it might look
familiar right you have a select filter
order by so additional operation data
frame operation and at the end I'm using
the show so again when I I can go to the
query history because everything is
registered and here you will see the
select from Filter or thereby so
everything that was I I created using
data frame was translated to SQL and was
pushed to the snowflake virtual
Warehouse
cluster so I'm operating using this this
uh this element right
now and so it's a SQL you can right you
can check the query plan so you can see
how it is executed you can here compare
I you can push that push the data frame
into pandas data frame so it's a single
operation to pandas but just to uh show
show you that the snow snowflake data
frame is snow park data frame is
doesn't uh consume any type of memory
onite inside your computer you you I run
this calculation so you can see that sow
Park data frame size zero megabyte when
but when I download it to pandas it
actually it's a local data pandas data
frame on my on my PC and because it's a
normal pandas data frame you can do
anything you like with it so if you were
working with pandas you can start
working with it again you can push some
kind of Wes group bu window functions
anything and then grab it convert to
pandas and just play with it a little
bit so about uh data exploration so we
have this functions like count and count
you don't need to wait for it because it
is St on this brain level on the the
service layer so this last layer of
snowflake so basically snowflake knows
how many records we have so it doesn't
need we don't need to execute the
statement snowflake will just give us
the result and even if the warehouse was
shut down it will not be turned on
automatic because it can be it will be
automatically turned on uh if we don't
if we need to execute but this this
particular query it's it's resides in
the cach layer I would say so you don't
need to you will you can grab this
information anytime for free pay for you
don't pay for it exactly so describe uh
so you can check the basic uh uh
statistics for it like minimum standard
devation max count mean and so on for
all the numerical variabl
and character variables text variables
as well uh so right now what I I will be
doing I want to create the linear
regression model so I need to check what
kind of variables I have which are
numeric which are reasonable maybe I
need to do some kind of like prep data
preparation remove the nles and so on so
basic this is what I will be doing right
now so I have two categorial
variables uh six seven numerical ones
so then I I'm doing some kind of uh uh
data distribution analysis what what
happens here is that uh he's pushing the
operation of calculations to the
Snowflake and returns just the outcomes
to visualize them on a client side
exactly so like you save a lot of time
because if you think about cartisan Joys
joins some extreme mats uh group eyes
partitioning of the whatever kind of
aggregate functions maybe geospatial
functions you wouldn't want to do it on
your laptop that has a limit of memory
instead you're pushing this down for
seconds in a very large environment just
to get the results
back
P pandas well with pandas it's a bit
different because pandas gives you a bit
more functions than the regular
frame yeah so if you want to do the plot
or some kind of visualization it
requires pandas data frame so and
[Music]
PES into the memory but with the
new with the new mod with modin yes the
idea will be to trick you into thinking
that your data frame has converted into
bandas on the Cent side but it will be
still pushing down to snowflake so we
are changing this to not force you to
pull pandas back to your memory but
generally pandas is one of the
environments or standards people like to
work with so that's why we don't have
full Integrity with with pandas so it
happens on your client side but with
data frames everything happens and
something like yeah so I don't want to
go through all of that so uh here are
some extra feature engineering
capabilities uh so for example sliding
window uh so you can do some kind of uh
Partition by calculations calculate
additional average location shift sale
like row by row and so on uh you can you
can do the utation with FNA uh function
with with column you can change it with
am to one and zero so plenty of stuff
that you it allows you to interact to
create your own columns create your own
features create your own objects like
tables and save it back into the
platform and if you imagine if you are
pushing all of the code for
Transformations into the platform you
can do operations on terabytes of data
and store it back as a new table as a
new object without pulling it to your
laptop so without wasting time for
moving the data back and forth and it's
very cheap it's safe and then actually
it's much faster than processing it on
anything else yeah so you can work on
gigabyte terabyte petabyte of data and
just pick up the correct virtual
Warehouse size and right now I'm I did
there some feature engineering some data
cleansing and so on right right now I'm
doing the random split and Save the
tables for a train and test and
everything was executed of course on
snowflake side so you can see like
create table insert into and so on all
of that statements uh were were pushed
to SN you can also see what's
interesting how large is the code in
Python comparing how large would it be
you have the same code or outcomes in
SQL basically not everything uh is yeah
like this one one line it's couple of
seq statements that's why quite often we
see people switching to functional
languages because it allows them to do
in one line something that requires I
don't know 100 lines in SQL especially
when you have nested
queries uh a lot of queries nested
within the query python is much more uh
effective but in the back engine will
convert it into its own SQL it looks
ugly as hell and no one who works with
data would be proud of this but it works
actually pretty fast but sfx optimizing
that query yes as well so you can send
it shet and it will be under the hot it
will look
beautiful generally negatively impacting
the performance yeah okay so I have the
train and test data set so right now
let's try to do some fitting uh so I
will create the stage stage is just the
object storage for saving files
basically drive it's a hard drive yeah
so I'm creating the stage where I will
put my
model uh here I'm using session file put
to put the can you tell what model yeah
well this is the linear regression so
here I'm doing the fitting with the
feature calls and Target call um array
so the whole data set was divided
samples for modeling and for validating
and right now will create a regression
model store it as a file like pickle or
anything else send it to that stage to
the volume that was created on snowflake
side so right now I'm actually compiling
it so it's it's run under the second
because it's right now it's on my local
environment and I need to register it on
on snowflake side using this session
aspro register so I'm registering this
function it will be called like this
it's a permanent so it will be pushed to
Snowflake and Stor as a normal functions
user so every user can use it and I'm
using those packages uh in this
particular function so when I press
run it will be running under the hood
something like Creator rep replace
procedure procedure will be pickled so
this is the this is bite code but it's
also gives you the information about the
source code that was uh used to to
create this this
thing what just happened that he created
a model outside and registered as a
someone working with powerbi Tableau
whatever has an option of inserting the
code directly can consume that function
as it would be already available in the
platform for pipelines for reporting
forer you so you can still continue on
the jupyter notebook so you can just uh
call that particular procedure to do the
model training and create the the model
itself uh but you can also do it from
the from the equal you can use this call
espro something like
this so either that way or other way
doesn't matter because it's already
stored as a permanent stor procedure so
anybody can execute it if they have
right I we mentioned about also about
snowflake ML and I said it's a wrapper
to the psyit learn and NJ boost so the
same thing that I did using this
procedure import pyic linear regression
and so on I can do it in couple of lines
using snow snow snowflake ml so it's
just simplified stuff what basically
it's doing exactly the same thing but
pushing down plat TR happens platform in
this case a lot of operations like
fature engineering can be pushed down
without entering into pandas what we
were talking about so it's it's also of
approach to give people an option to
choose what they want to work with
either with SQL with pandas with data
frames train outside train inside
or maybe use pre-trained models we are
having it's your choice but generally it
should be easy for people um available
yeah so this is a this will create the
snowflake ml linear regression model um
but if you will check check it under the
hood basically it will do exactly the
same thing like we did the couple lines
above so it will convert create dump and
so on so but it's just simple simpler
you don't don't need to write a lot of
code and achieve the same result but at
the end you can just convert it to
psychic L object and work it as a normal
psychic Lear
model and so there's a couple of uh
extra statistics about uh coefficients
variable coefficients and so
on uh you can view the model that is
stored on the stage and so on but let's
move further just to not I already pass
the time but I I'm I'm just finishing so
next one so I have the model everything
is drained so I need to create the user
defined function to score to to uh do
the model
inference so what I will be doing what
I'm doing here I'm declaring the the the
function actually two functions load
model and linear regression predict
local sales it will be using data frame
so it will not run row by row during the
scoring you can pass hund like thousand
of rows to it and it it will return
return thousand of rows uh in return so
you it's it's it will run much faster
basically so this this function loads
the model do the prediction and return
the results so it's pretty simple
function uh again I need to register it
as the permanent user defined
function and I can do the prediction I
don't want to wait so I want to scale up
my warehouse to medium so make to run it
faster and I can just use this train
Snow Park The F select and call UDF over
here to do the actual prediction and if
we go over here to check the SQL
statement you can
see here is my function inside plain SQL
so you can use this function in plain
SQL in Tableau or powerbi or DB Weaver
anywhere basically can you quickly
explain what is the difference between
the spr before andf right now yeah the
espro is just a pure python code
executed on the on the sandbox on the
python sandbox it's pure python it's
it's a few operations happening as one
execution so you bundle operations
together to train the model the feature
engineering whatever do the pipelines
and in the end the outcome of that
stroke would be a file that can be
registered as a UDF so UDF is basically
something that's more digestible for
users of the platform and it can be
tabular UDF it can be vectorized UDF or
can be scalar UDF really depends how you
how you design it and what is the need
behind
it yeah
so maybe just let's not go yeah deep
yeah so this is the exactly the same
thing that you can do I will not run it
using the snowflake LM ml so you can
just run LM predict uh LM is the model
that train above using snowflake ML and
at at the end you can do the evaluation
but basically it creates of course the
same results the snowflake ML and psych
it because it's it's the same code under
the hood at the end you can uh visualize
it on the map for example those results
uh if you want to predict and you can
use various of tools for it and one of
the tools and this is the really last
thing I want to present is uh something
that is called uh stream lead so it's a
pretty nice uh python Library open
source python library that can be used
to create simply create visualization it
it uses some something that is called
widgets widgets are the elements type
part of the visualization uh it's the
elements that you will visualize in the
app so as you can see you can use the St
WR to write the text h St liner chart to
create the chart and the elements will
be interactive but what how it's connect
to snowflake first of all snowflake
bought stream lead but it still remains
open source as the part but the second
second thing that is really relevant is
that you can execute those streamlit
application inside
Snowflake and uh tasty by forecast over
here so you don't need to provision the
infrastructure you don't need to create
the environment to to to create it you
can write your own P snow stream lead
application inside Snowflake and run it
let's run it maybe for war so or
k or so you can create the shift pick up
the shift and just update and create the
the running application inside snowflake
so it's snowflake has multiple purposes
you can use it for many different things
including hosting the hosting the
application so right now as you can see
it's a normal interactive map hosted on
inside snow flag and what what what is
coming as well is that you will be able
to monetize that application inside
snowflake Marketplace so you can create
your own applications or your own data
listings and sell it and monetize it
inside snowflake
ecosystem uh
so that's it from my
side
yes system how it
works the question is how it works yeah
how do you Val because like anyone who
work with Cloud Partners know that it's
not seconds to spin and this is
snowflake magic no there is no magic
unfortunately so snowflake is keeping
something that is called hot pool of the
machines we have we have thousands
generally we are one of the biggest
consumers of aure and AWS I think
comparable to Netflix and everything
that you find as large companies so we
are paying for them but not the
customers customers only pays for them
when they turn it on we have we have a
pool of thousands of virtual machines
and when you spin up the
cluster these machines from the pool are
allocated to your name space and then
when you turn it down it goes back to
the pool and it's going through a pool
which is kind of destroying the hardes
memory for
that
connectors so what was the question
which part of the snowflake are open
source which part of snowflake are open
source that's a difficult question
because snowflake is not open source as
I said stream lead is a kind of library
that is open source data frame standard
is open
connector connectors libraries I'm not
sure connectors stream lead uh I think
iceberg is open source yeah and we are
contributing to that so iceberg is the
the Delta killer parts of those but for
example if you would if you would be
I don't know a freelancer or would
represent the company and you've created
a kind of storage procedure that
requires very abstract kind of data set
I know for retail exam for example and
an input would be uh customer history
time series uh you can expose the sprog
on Marketplace aser said which means
that every other customer of snowflake
can buy this SP for you and for example
train their model because you've created
a very Universal kind of a logic for
training model so voice can can sell
your your tuned llms inside Snowflake
and actually we are working on with one
of the Polish partner that
is right now uh doing the private
preview for monetizing logic inside
marketpl is having logic which are udfs
and strokes but also having data for
example I don't know Master Card can
sell you information if you're a
retailer what are the segments that are
buying using the card and how the
transactions are going Vision sales data
about haror fact set is selling
information about what is happening on
the stock market so every customer of
snowflake is interconnected it's a large
web and that logic that seems to be
interesting if you can contribute you
can expose it for free you may decide
like this is the code on G it's for free
you want to use it and contribute or you
can try to monetize it
so so snowflake itself is not question
not everything is open source yeah but
there are elements of that are yeah and
snowflake is contributing to couple of
projects as well so if you are really
interested into and want to learn more
feel invite you will not be invited
anymore feel invited to build local this
the biggest event that we are organizing
in our region it will be hosted in warso
Because by the way one of the uh creator
of snowflake is Polish yeah Martin OSI
and he is creator of of snowflake snow
snowflake have the third biggest we are
fighting for the second but right now
it's third biggest R&D centers in the
whole world located in wara so we have a
little bit of Polish Roots inside the
company so if you are interested uh this
is the engineering uh conference it's
not like the marketing uh we are doing
marketing conference at the beginning of
the year this one is we are aiming for
engineers data scientists there will be
a Hands-On workshops uh streaming uh
Workshop as well there will be
additional things about snow park and so
on so feel
invited there a few sessions about LM
exactly no questions okay let's WRA
right so let's
thank pizza is ready so feel free to
grab a bite